not everyone with the coronavirus gets
sick and of those who are sick only a
small percentage die the infection
fatality rate varies widely it's as high
as 13% in Italy and closer to 3% in
Canada but none of that of course means
anything if your loved one is one of
those statistics kovat 19 is so
infectious people are often dying alone
and as Ross Lord reports those left
behind are grieving alone three weeks
have passed since the death of Sophia
Lansky's brother Anthony their family is
unable to grieve collectively because
the threat of kovat 19 has forced her
elderly mother Enid into isolation it's
been very hard for her you know we speak
probably two times a day and stay
connected with each other that way and
there's a lot of Tears a lot of
reminiscing the family of Ken Weiland
can relate for two weeks after he became
infected with kovat 19 he was completely
off limits standard policy aimed at
limiting the spread of the virus
the were astounded that we couldn't you
know it's like they had taken away my
father and lock him up that was a you
know that was the way I felt about it my
sisters felt about it in the end they
were finally allowed a short visit to
see their father just before he passed
away the emotional extremes combined
with the constant stress of life during
a pandemic and the edicts around
physical distancing are taking a toll on
Canadians according to this grief
counselor there is definitely something
a phenomenom of survivor's guilt and
guilt in general of not being able to
say goodbye or what what I could have
done differently as the virus sweeps
through long term care homes across
Canada so does the feeling of isolation
and sorrow that natural gestures of
compassion are forbidden and you find
yourself taking that initial step
forward and then you have to say whoa
and and step back again
and and it's unnatural but it's becoming
the new natural
we for Reverend Bill Mercer it's
heartbreaking life-affirming gestures
are all he knows i baptize you in the
name of the Father and of the Son and of
the Holy Spirit
suddenly the choirs in the congregation
are gone leaving only a lonely live
stream however these are different times
and different circumstances in his
province Newfoundland and Labrador most
covered 19 cases have been traced to a
single funeral home gathering funerals
and wakes are banned no more than five
people are permitted at a burial even in
formal processions have been shut down
because people started gathering in
groups on the roadside when I see a
family at the graveside my initial
instinct is to you know either to extend
a hand to say you know I'm sorry for
your loss or you know if you know
someone even on it you know a closer
basis to offer a hug and at this time
we're just not allowed to do that and
and you wrestle with it you struggle
with it and at times you hate yourself
because you're not able to do it it's
not only grieving this restricted
distancing rules are stifling those
once-in-a-lifetime moments like first
time grandparents touching a precious
newborn and when I found out that none
of us could see him none of us could go
in and everything it was just like this
won't be happening this just can't be
happening and they took out of this over
the car in his kursi bumped him on the
driveway and said okay you can't come
any closer
for now they'll get by watching videos
of their grandson Nico emerging into
this world those suffering apart from
loved ones who are dying faced a much
more excruciating ordeal if you're
grieving know that you're not alone we
are here for you Sophia loss in ski is
finding ways to remember her brother
I have Anthony with me right now these
are his gloves and we're holding each
other's hands even
he's not here he's he's with me every
single day she wants desperately for her
entire family to mark her brother's
death and scatter his ashes together
we're gonna hold each other and we're
gonna cry and we're gonna laugh and
we're just going to be shoulder to
shoulder there's no way of knowing when
that will happen as Canada struggles to
withstand this crisis and Canadians
struggle in isolation
[Music]